gislen le nouvel découvre la linogravure
sur une plaque elle reproduit un tableau
qu'elle a choisi
nféa de monnaie le geste des mains est
lent gislen souffre d'un handicap moteur
depuis l'enfance j'essaie de faire au
mieux faire au mieux et faire bien une
fois par semaine des ateliers d'art
plastique sont ainsi proposés par
l'association des Paralysés de France
installé à voisin le Bretonneux on
essaie de s'adapter avec les moyens du
bord
et puis on trouve des petites
astuces selon ce qu'on fait vous trouvez
quelle astuce par exemple pour graver la
grav c'est même exer en fait j'ai trouvé
d'autres m pour m'aider à ten dire la
plaque et après moi je fais le
reste ici dans cet atelier de peinture
et de gravure h élèves sont inscrits ils
sont handicapés moteur pour la plupart
le temps de l'atelier on oublie un peu
tout pour déjàir les copines et puis
progresser dans la peinture au début je
savais pas du tout peindre maintenant
j'arrive mieux à faire des dessins je me
débrouille de faire des choses comme ça
c'est c'est une évasion c'est oublier
les petits soucis la vie quotidienne
comme tout le monde c'est pas toujours
simple mais justement on essaie
d'évoluer hein pour progresser malgré
ses difficultés
u dei en et éolueron peut faire
plastiquees ateliers sont également
ouvert au personnes valid une exposition
commune de peinture et de sculpture a
lieu à la fin de
l'année